hey guys just wanted to wrap up kind of
this open suse linux thing i've been
doing and also give a few channel
updates
it's it's been pretty interesting
switching to linux as you might know if
you followed um my last few videos
basically i
just put linux on my machine
and not like beside windows but
replacing windows entirely
and i just wanted to see if i could do
like my daily workflow and get stuff
done only relying on linux and i plan to
do this for the entire month of march
but i don't think i can do that i kind
of need windows at this point it's
getting actually really frustrating i
will explain because i still do love
linux i think it's great for some things
but for me right now as a daily driver i
don't think i can do it so
let me bring up a few things and i'll
switch this other screen
uh
here we go here we go okay i and i also
just want to give you some insights on
as to some things that are coming up
that i'm kind of working on because i am
preparing a few talks in the future
so basically like here's my channel so
my linux videos haven't exactly been as
popular
as usual they they've definitely got
some pretty quick well they're it's not
like huge numbers you know so it's
without a
big sample size it's hard to be real
sure but in general it seems like most
people don't particularly like these
linux videos as much as my other videos
which is a bit understandable they're a
little bit weird
and
they're actually really hard to produce
i've been using this software
called open shot and i just want to talk
about that very briefly it's a little
buggy i don't have it updated though
because you have to like manually update
it and i didn't feel like dealing with
it to be honest but this software is
what i've been using to edit and it's
okay it has some really nice features
and some really user friendly features
like when you go to render it's uh it's
super easy to just pick the right format
and get it done it renders really fast
so that's super nice
because you can just do that you can
just drag in stuff it's pretty easy to
make titles it's pretty easy to use
that's probably the best thing about
openshot
so as you can see there's an update
available but when you go to it
it's i could probably figure it out but
honestly i'm just not very motivated to
figure it out at this point because i i
don't plan on keeping this os
so
all right there's a
a couple main problems i have with
though this os and
the audio is one of them so we're just
going to say that but
i do love this default
gnome interface and the way they have it
set up
it is it is very
it's very pretty
and it was a little laggy and slow until
i got the graphics drivers figured out i
talked about that in other videos so i
don't want to talk about it too much but
one of the biggest issues i have with
this os is the sound the sound has been
driving me crazy and i don't mean like
the sound effects and the windows
effects or anything like that
it's just a little bit glitchy so every
time i boot this thing up
or every time it goes to sleep and i
have to log back in
it sets my sound device to the wrong
device now there's probably some way to
change that
but i just
i don't feel like digging into it at
this point you know
so basically every time i log in i have
to go to this and go pick the right
device because it defaults to one of my
monitors and speakers are playing so
i'll go to do something and my speakers
are blaring and that's like the worst
thing to happen you know because maybe
you're watching something that you don't
want everyone around you to know about
or who knows it might be private
so it's just no good when that happens
and i have to do it every time and it's
just it's getting them to be annoyed you
know i'm willing to bet someone out
there is like oh just change this but
why wouldn't it just remember
the device i set it to the last time
and the time you know so there's that
that's one thing
but there is more stuff than that
there's
listening i thought i heard some these
headphones like block out all sound um
so another problem i've been having
pretty consistently
is scratchiness like when i'm coding and
working and stuff i often like to listen
to music
but after a while music starts to get
like this scratchy sound in it and all
especially it seems like after i hit
compile like if i compile code
whatever music i've been playing starts
getting scratchy and that's like driving
me crazy because
i like good crystal clear sound and
it's not happening very easily now i did
find a few workarounds to make that
better but it doesn't make it perfect
like if i'm listening to something on
youtube like a big mix or something
that's like an hour long
after playing for a while it'll get
scratchy and i'll just have all this
little scratchy sound and i try to
record it to get like a sample
but actually obs doesn't even pick up
the scratchiness so i don't i don't know
what that is exactly
but also in addition to it being
scratchy it gets really delayed so when
you're watching like a video it looks
like the sound's out of sync but the
sound's not out of sync it's just
something with the audios going on
but i did find out that if you
enable the hardware
i'll just show real quick so if you go
two settings
you guys probably already know where
this is
uh well somewhere in here there's an
enable
the the hardware
i can't think of a word
words are not coming to me right now
somewhere in here there's there's use
accelerated hardware when available that
seemed to help the whole scratchiness
thing so the scratching just kind of
went away but it still gets really laggy
and out of sync so
i don't know i could try a different
browser
sure i could try all sorts of things but
like how much do i really want to mess
with it and that's the thing this is
this is kind of the point i'm getting to
like you can get things to work i in
general was able to get things to work i
can play league of legends with my
friends i can get on discord i can play
valheim i can play
all the games i can't seem to play
magically gathering arena because i like
play every once in a while so i haven't
played that in quite a while
so i'm kind of wanting to get a few
games in at some point but i seem to be
able to do all my coding
and uh
you know of course you can't i can't do
the windows stuff which my little game
engine i've been working on was on
windows i thought about
redoing it making it like all set up
with cmake for linux or any os
and i was probably going to do that
within a day or two i still might do
that actually but
basically what it comes down to is
that's not going to be
something i want to do because i'm
probably going to listen to music while
i'm doing it and the music is going to
get all annoying maybe scratchy or
really laggy or you know there's just
there's just all these little things
that keep adding up that just are little
frustrations that i didn't have when i
was using windows and you know this is
just
opensuse 15.2
so maybe if i tried a different version
of linux it would be different
but
if it's anything like it was when i last
tried
linux and used it a lot it's probably
not going to be much different i tried
out a bunch of different distros when i
was in college a couple years ago and
the conclusion i basically came to was
they're all about the same they all
generally had approximately the same
problems because i don't think it's the
distro this problem there's something
else there's like the people who are
making the drivers for the hardware and
when people make different distros they
don't make different drivers too they're
still using the same drivers so there's
just kind of a lack of support
from the hardware makers and stuff like
that that i assume is going on more than
anything because these distros are
beautiful there's there's a whole bunch
more i want to try people have been
recommending a bunch people have been
recommending like
uh what garuda and some others
and i could probably yeah we could
probably take a peek here like i think
it was in this one
yeah let me just take a look at the
comments
here someone said uh try gentoo
i'd like to try gentoo
um
other people have noted that they can
also play demanding games with ultra
graphics so
yeah i kind of found that experience too
the video drivers are good the video
drivers seem to be
getting up to par so shout out to nvidia
and amd and intel for keeping up but
someone's not keeping up there's some
other issues
mainly with the sound and it's not bad
the sound used to be much worse i
remember the sound having even more
issues so it had less issues than when i
last tried
and someone said it's kind of buggy i
try pop os
or
bloated and buggy i i don't
i think the buggy i don't think the
bugginess is coming from open soos
itself and i don't i don't know what's
bloated about it exactly it doesn't seem
bloated to me
so
i kind of need a little bit more of an
explanation as to why on that but i've
always heard that papa os was really
bloated but i don't know i might try pop
os arch
so there's a lot of oh yeah garuda
someone wants me to try groot up prodon
db lutress and i'm sure these are all
beautiful distros that will handle games
fine
and i'm guessing they'll all have the
same little weird sound sync issue too
so because that i think that's more
related to firefox and audio drivers at
this point and yeah
i know i could try different browsers
don't know if i'm going to though
all right so i i am going to try for the
rest of this month i'm going to find a
machine probably one of my secondary
machines or something and put some
different versions of linux on it not on
a
not on a virtual machine but on an
actual
piece of hardware and try some of them
out i do want to try these out they look
really nice
and i want to see if these uh
how they are but on my main machine i
think i've got to go back to windows
all right and what else i i said i was
going to
talk a little bit about what i got
coming up yeah i'm working on a couple
different talks and i'm kind of like
some prototypes of them i'm not real
happy with them so i'm not going to
release them yet and i'm going to talk
about
tips for getting through a computer
science degree if you're struggling
i've got a video on that coming up that
i i'm kind of working on and i've also
got another one that stemmed from a
comment about how to find motivation
to continue looking for a job and
working in projects after you've been
burned and kind of got a bad feeling
about the industry so
working on those two talks and uh
i'll probably just do a little bit of
side content here and there about what
else i'm doing in the meantime
i'm going to do some more updates on the
patreon page i want to put a new pull up
about stuff to work on and i think the
main things i'm going to list are things
like the talks about the industry
motivational stuff
and
just coding tech tutorials i know a lot
of people are here for the coding tech
tutorials i don't know why i keep almost
saying tectorials it's not a word but uh
and also
video editing tutorials are just
software tutorials so i'm kind of trying
to come up with a nice concise list that
doesn't have a bunch of overlap like
things that are approximately the same
um so if you have any ideas of what else
might be really cool to put on this sort
of channel i'm open to hear i'm into all
sorts of things i
kind of trying to keep it related to
tech but i have
i'm one of those people that just has
too many hobbies so
i feel like i could do a tutorial on
anything or videos about anything but i
don't really have the time to do that so
that's kind of what i'm running into
with my life is i have all these things
i want to do and i don't have enough
time to do them all so i've really got
to pick and choose but also
i don't want to like make stuff that
nobody's interested in so it's kind of
hard to choose and also
at this point i have a ton of videos and
you know my channel is not huge or
anything but it's getting to the point
where i get quite a few comments every
day
and that's really cool i love reading
them but also it's a lot to keep up with
there's a lot of little requests here
and there and some of them i really want
to do
um but it's like uh after a while they
kind of get overrun because you know a
couple days will go by a lot of other
things will come up and i'm not sure
what is best to spend my time on at that
point so i kind of just do whatever i
think would be
something i'm most interested in doing
and feel like doing
but if you want to have a little more
influence sign up on patreon i'll put up
a poll and i will do some user request
videos
over there and there's a bunch of other
features too like we have a private
discord
that could use some more people so
please do sign up get in there
talk about all sorts of things also i'm
considering doing some other things like
someone mentioned i should
make the discord public i'm not sure
about that yet
i've considered it but then yeah i would
have to get mods for sure but then what
do i do with the patrons who have paid
to get on there you know do i give them
a user role i kind of gotta i want to
ask them see what they think or maybe i
should just do what i think is best and
and kind of go from there
so there's a lot of considerations you
know to go forward
something like this and
what else what else
no live streaming occasionally i do live
streaming
now
the thing with me live streaming and the
reason i don't live stream much for the
most part i really like live streaming
but i kind of want to have like a clear
goal in mind i don't want to just like
go live and just be like doing nothing
you know
i want to have something
uh like a goal in mind or maybe that
doesn't matter maybe you guys just want
to see me goofing around doing whatever
the heck i'm doing anyway you know i
don't i don't really know to be honest
or just hanging out and chatting but
also i usually do that when i'm home
alone so when everyone else leaves the
house that's usually when my stream time
is just because i don't want to
bother everybody and i don't want to
necessarily have interruptions of like
things that could be not really suited
to be on the internet like i do want to
keep my
private life separate from the internet
um i think most people can respect and
understand that but
you know it's just
it seems like a smart thing to do at
this point and in general you probably
don't want to
um you know blast all your private
information a bunch of people that don't
actually know you
so that's where i'm at hope you guys
have enjoyed this update
and we'll see in the next video peace
out keep coding stay strong
i don't know why i said stay strong but
yeah just keep keep your mind sharp i
guess
that's uh
i never know how to end these
i guess i'm just saying what what i
would like to hear sometimes all right
peace out guys